vielen dank guten morgen von meiner
seite wir haben zu dieser
pressekonferenz eingeladen um sie
darüber zu informieren dass hier nach
abstimmung in der bundesregierung
gestern und nach informationen der
europäischen partner heute jetzt in
diesem moment die alarmstufe das
ausrufen wir haben in deutschland eine
störung der gasversorgung so ist
definiert daher ist es erforderlich
diese alarmstufe auszurufen
gas ist von nun an ein knappes gut in
deutschland das sage ich obwohl oder
gerade weil die versorgungssicherheit in
deutschland aktuell gewährleistet ist
der markt ist also in der lage die
mengen die benötigt werden um die
versorgungssicherheit in deutschland zu
gewährleisten und auch die speicher
moderat anzufüllen auf dem markt zu
besorgen
dennoch und das zwingt uns zu diesem
schritt heute darf die aktuelle lage uns
nicht in eine falsche sicherheit in
einer falschen sicherheit werden wir
haben nachdem in der letzten woche
russland gazprom unter einem
vorgeschobenen technischen argument die
gaslieferungen auf der nord stream
pipeline um 60 prozent reduziert hat
verschiedene szenarien durchgerechnet
diese szenarien
zeige ich ihnen einmal
das ist nämlich ich finde sehr
anschaulich zu sehen wo man da gerade
steht die roten punkte sind die
gesetzlich vorgegebenen speicher soll
füllstände die blaue kurve also quasi
der optimale verlauf unter der annahme
von einer reduktion von nord stream 61
prozent also den minus 40 prozent ist
die kurve die wir erreichen sollen sie
ist allerdings nur möglich zu erreichen
unter der annahme dass wir nicht für das
europäische nachbarland aus speichern
das ist erstens ungesetzlich und
zweitens wäre es auch absurd weil wir ja
darauf angewiesen sind dass die
europäischen länder uns beliefern also
niederlande norwegen benelux belgien
frankreich
alle diese länder
brauchen wir ja um überhaupt über
energie gas gas nach deutschland zu
bekommen insofern und das ist die
not das ist die erkenntnis die und zu
diesem tag führte scheidet diese kurve
per logik und per gesetz aus bleiben die
verschiedenen anderen szenarien und sie
sehen hier ist die nulllinie hier sind
die speicher leer dass die meisten
szenarien uns sehr weit in die zone von
lehrern speichern führen deswegen greift
die definition des gesetzes ich erlaube
mir sich einmal vorzulesen die
alarmstufe wird dann ausgerufen wenn
eine störung der gasversorgung oder eine
außergewöhnlich hohe nachfrage nach gas
vorliegt die zu einer erheblichen
verschlechterung der gas versorgungslage
führt der markt aber noch in der lage
ist diese störung oder nachfrage zu
bewältigen ohne das nicht marktbasierte
maßnahmen ergriffen werden müssen dieser
fall liegt vor wir haben uns die paar
tage zeit gelassen die szenarien
durchzurechnen das ist kein spiel wir
müssen einen so gravierenden schritt gut
begründen können und die begründung ist
aus meiner sicht schlagend
wir sind also jetzt gehalten die
gasverbraucher zu reduzieren jetzt schon
im sommer dann vor allem mit der
perspektive auf den winter und das ist
sicherlich
die trügerische wirklichkeit in der wir
uns im moment bewegen es ist sommer und
zwar ein sommer nach einer langen kann
die mietzeit main will gerne draußen die
zeit genießen man will auch vielleicht
mal ohne politische trübsal im kopf die
zeit genießen aber der winter wird ja
kommen wir müssen also jetzt die
vorsorge treffen um dann im winter
vorbereitet zu sein und alles daran
setzen dass wir mit vollen
speicherstände in den winter gehen
ich will ausdrücklich unterstreichen
dass diese situation ja immer eine
bedrohung war und so hat sich die
bundesregierung seit amtsantritt seit
dezember auf dieses szenario vorbereitet
wir haben vor angefangen alternative
infrastrukturen zu schaffen die lng
terminals mit hochgeschwindigkeit zu
bauen beziehungsweise die pipeline
anschlüsse zu bauen für die fsa user für
diversifizierung schiffe wir haben früh
angefangen mit steuergeld gasmengen zu
besorgen und über den winter zu kommen
beziehungsweise die
kapazitäten die nicht durch den markt
befüllt werden aufzufüllen das schließt
auch den speicher reden den gast kaum
speicher reden mit ein wir haben die
verschiedenen gesetze geschrieben die es
uns jetzt ermöglichen auch
gesetzgeberisch tätig zu werden das gas
einspeicherung ausgesetzt das energie
sicherungs gesetz all die gesetze zum
ausbau der erneuerbaren die sich jetzt
in der parlamentarischen beratung
befinden die also dann die energiemenge
hoffentlich zeitnah erhöhen
ich will und ich muss an dieser stelle
sagen dass sich natürlich auch recht
dass wir in den letzten jahren in
deutschland nicht gut genug waren es
sind die versäumnisse der letzten dekade
die uns jetzt in dieser bedrängnis
geführt haben und damit meine ich nicht
nur die politisch falsche abhängigkeit
von russland sondern auch die fehlende
bereitschaft alternativen zu schaffen
wie anders ständen wir da wenn wir die
letzten jahre in der energieeffizienz
und den ausbau der erneuerbaren wirklich
massiv voran gekommen wären statt
einfach nur im stillstand zu verharren
das rächt sich jetzt und muss mit großer
geschwindigkeit aufgeholt werden
dass das nicht von heute auf morgen gibt
es einen klar aber von heute auf
übermorgen sollte erreichbar sein um
dieses übermorgen zu erreichen sind wir
gezwungen maßnahmen zu treffen die
wirklich weh tun wir haben sie schon am
wochenende angekündigt zu nennen sind
dass wir die
kohlekraftwerke aus der reserve in den
betrieb bringen werden umso mit gas vom
markt zu nehmen gas für die
elektrifizierung vom markt zu nehmen um
dieses gas dann ein speichern zu können
wir werden ein gas spa auktionsmodell
vorliegen das ist der industrie noch mal
erlaubt gegen geld leihen um eine
umlagefinanzierung
gasverbraucher aus dem betrieb zu nehmen
und gestern hat nach beratungen im
haushaltsausschuss der gesetzgeber 15
milliarden euro für den markt
gebietsverantwortlichen also trading cup
europe das ist der die tochter
unternehmer der gasnetzbetreiber 15
milliarden euro freizugeben um gas
einzukaufen für die weitere speicherung
die alarmstufe gesetzlich geboten nach
den analysen die wir haben ist außerdem
die grundlage für weitere schritte und
die werden wir gehen sobald die gesetze
verabschiedet sind beziehungsweise
sobald die notwendigkeit es gebietet
zwei beispiele will ich nehme einmal im
parlamentarischen verfahren befindet
sich in der endabstimmung das
kraftwerksbereich haltungs gesetz
dieses gesetz ist dann die grundlage
dafür dass wir die kohlekraftwerke rein
nehmen können es wird wenn der bundestag
so dieses gesetz verabschiedet wie
geplant dann am 8.7 den bundesrat
passieren und dann werden die
verordnungen vorliegen die teilweise an
die ausrufung der alarmstufe gebunden
sind die verordnung werden jetzt unter
hochdruck geschrieben und die
kraftwerksbetreiber die dann mit den
verordnungen
[Musik]
ihre kohlekraftwerke in den markt
bringen sind angeschrieben worden dass
es so kommen wird die werden also jetzt
schon die kohle bereitstellen die
kraftwerke wieder flott machen für den
einsatz dann in zweieinhalb wochen
das zweite was ich nennen will und was
immer mit der alarmstufe auch öffentlich
verknüpft wurde ist der paragraph 24
energie sicherungs gesetz endlich ist
der paragraph für die weitergabe von
preisen auch außerhalb der verträge
erlaubt er ist an die voraussetzung der
alarmstufe gebunden aber es gibt kein
automatismus und deswegen werden wir ihn
heute nicht ziehen noch nicht ausrufen
der grund ist dass wir den markt weiter
beobachten wollen die
ziehung des paragrafen 24n sieg ist
daran gebunden dass die
bundesnetzagentur eine weitere störung
und zwar eine strukturelle störung der
gras flüsse feststellt deswegen werden
wir haben wir die voraussetzung jetzt
hier mit geschaffen werden ihnen aber
heute noch nicht ausrufen
damit bin ich beim preis denn para 24n
sieg würde eine preis weitergabe der gas
betreiber außerhalb der verträge
bedeuten diese preise werden zu tragen
seien von der wirtschaft von den
verbrauchern und von den verbrauchern
und unabhängig davon ob man 24n sieht
oder nicht die preise kommen bei den
verbraucherinnen und bei den
verbrauchern an das was wir also hier im
moment erleben ist eine extreme
belastung für viele menschen für viele
unternehmerinnen und unternehmer diese
belastung ist ein externer schock es ist
ja nicht die
schlüssigkeit der deutschen
volkswirtschaft die uns zu dieser
situation geführt hat sondern der krieg
in russland und durch den krieg und
durch die politisch induzierten
verknappung von fossilen rohstoffen
die die der druck der im land aufgebaut
wurde diese preise müssen also getragen
werden dass die faire getragen werden
und dass es entsprechend entlastung gibt
für die haushalte und für die
unternehmen die sich nicht leisten
können das ist die aufgabe der nächsten
wochen das boot zu analysieren und dort
abhilfe beziehungsweise unterstützung zu
schaffen bleibt als letztes zu sagen
dass wir obwohl es sommer ist alle einen
beitrag leisten können die unternehmerin
und die unternehmer in dem sie schauen
welche einsparpotenziale noch da sind
und ich weiß dass sie das tun es gibt
berechnungen ist der gasverbrauch in der
deutschen industrie in den letzten
monaten ungefähr acht prozent
zurückgegangen ist
aber auch privathaushalte können ein
unterschied jetzt schon machen ich weiß
dass das manchmal banal klingt aber
diese banalität muss man immer mit 41
millionen haushalten multiplizieren und
bevor der winter kommt macht es eben
sinn die heizung noch einmal vernünftig
einzustellen oder einen hydraulischen
abgleich durchzuführen und die summen an
energie wie auch an geld die dort zu
sparen sind sind durchaus
erheblich bis zu 15 prozent
beispielsweise an
heizkostenersparnis kann man machen nur
durch den hydraulischen abgleich also
nur dadurch dass die heizung vernünftig
eingestellt sind und das wäre dann ja
entsprechend die energiemenge und das
nehmen wir jetzt mit 41 millionen
haushalten multipliziert und dann sieht
man dass die kleinen teilweise so
belächelten banalen schritte in der
summe dann doch einen großen unterschied
machen diesen unterschied müssen sie
aber machen wir befinden uns in einer
ökonomischen auseinandersetzung mit
russland gas und energie wird als waffe
gegen deutschland eingesetzt aus meiner
sicht mit dem ziel das was das land in
den letzten wochen und monaten
ausgezeichnet hat und europa
ausgezeichnet hat zu zerstören nämlich
eine große geschlossenheit eine große
solidarität mit der ukraine und eine
große bereitschaft für die verteidigung
von freiheit auch einen preis zu zahlen
über die preiste warte soll genau dies
zerstört werden das wiederum darf nicht
passieren deswegen müssen alle
politischen maßnahmen ergriffen werden
dass wir genug gas haben wie eben
ausgeführt dass die lasten in
deutschland fair verteilt werden aber
nicht dass das land in einen zustand
gerät wie wir ihn auch an anderen
stellen schon hatten wo wir nicht über
die richtigkeit von verschiedenen
maßnahmen streiten sondern darüber
streiten und für nicht putin seinen
willen lassen sollen das wäre fatal und
deswegen ist das was wir hier gerade
machen eine kollektive eine nationale
kraftanstrengung die wir nur gemeinsam
bestehen werden vielen dank
vielen dank ich habe die ersten fragen
ich fange an im raum
herr delfs dann jako meyer und frau
herzog wir machen eine frage nach der
anderen also frage antwort wenn es am
ende knapp wird mit der zeit bin ich
aber erstmal ohne hair days bitte herr
minister können sie ganz kurz noch mal
erklären mit der preisbildung als wenn
ich es richtig verstanden haben ja die
konsumenten jetzt erstmal die
preiserhöhung gar nicht zu spüren
bekommen richtig sondern das ist ja eine
preisbildung erstmal am markt sie
stattfindet das heißt die gasunternehmen
die gaslieferanten erfahren diese
preissteigerung aber aber nicht erst mal
die konsumenten weil das wird nicht
weitergegeben ab welchem punkt wird es
weiter geben können sie das noch mal
kurz erklären und warum wird es jetzt
noch nicht weiter und noch mal ganz kurz
für dumme
ganz so ist es nicht die preise werden
ja weitergegeben wenn sie
auf ihre rechnung geschaut haben werden
sie vermutlich gesehen haben dass sie es
ist die abschlagszahlung für das nächste
jahr schon angehoben wurden und zwar je
nach gas oder energieversorger deutlich
also da sind tatsächlich steigerung von
200 prozent zu verzeichnen und manchmal
mehr und das ist ein rollierendes system
die verträge werden in der regel
jährlich angepasst einige stadtwerke
oder versorger machen jetzt schon höhere
abschläge aber die preisvergabe erfolgt
schritt für schritt je nach stadtgebiet
oder nach haushalt schon jetzt davon
abgesetzt ist der paragraph 24 m sieg
der die preis weitergabe in den
bestehenden verträgen quasi sofort
ermöglicht der hintergrund ist dass die
versorgungsunternehmen
laufende verträge haben
die in der regel oder je nachdem wie
abhängig die von russischen gas sind das
jetzt ja blockiert wird und dann auf dem
gasmarkt auf dem spot-markt neu besorgt
werden muss zu deutlich höheren preisen
je nachdem welche verträge sie haben
machen sie mit jedem tag mit jeder woche
ein - und sollte dieses - so groß werden
dass die unternehmen ist nicht mehr
tragen können und sie umfallen droht der
gesamte markt irgendwann umzufallen also
einen basiseffekt im energiesystem die
versorger wie die stadtwerke nicht mehr
die stadtwerke nicht mehr die
nachgelagerten kunden und dann kann man
sich vorstellen was dann in deutschland
passiert dafür ist der 24 m sieg gedacht
aber eben wie gesagt noch nicht gezogen
weil wir schauen wollen wie sich die
situation weiterentwickelt dieser
paragraph er ist noch nicht das
schärfste schwert dass wir politisch in
der hand haben aber ein doch so scharfe
schwert dass es mit großem bedacht und
großer gedacht angewandt werden muss
dann bitte am herr kummer ja
wenn man schon beim § 24 sind sehen wir
gesagt dass in der presseaussendung das
ist eine verstetigung der gasmenge lage
dann eine anzeige durch die
bundesnetzagentur im bundesanzeiger
erforderlich machen würde das wäre ja
dann wenn der paragraf 24 in kraft
treten würde nach meinem verständnis
jetzt ist die frage wenn aus nord stream
1 nachdem wartungen im juli kein gas
mehr kommen wird wird dann der paragraf
24 zum einsatz kommen
ich möchte nicht über den zeitpunkt
spekulieren so wie wir arbeiten das
haben sie ja eben gesehen werden wir
immer die grundlagen analysieren um dann
die vorbereiteten nächsten schritte zu
gehen
aber sie haben im der nebenbemerkung ein
erwartbares und einfach auf deutschland
zukommen das datum angesprochen am 11
sie benötigen aus dem einst pipeline
etatmäßig gewartet diese wartungszeit
hat in den letzten jahren ungefähr zehn
tage gedauert in diesen zehn tagen wird
kein gas über nord stream einst nach
deutschland fließen und entsprechend der
frage wie jetzt
effizienzmaßnahmen wirken wie wir
energie gas auf dem weltmarkt besorgen
können und die sich die einspeicherung
bis dahin entwickeln
verschlimmert sich im grunde dann in
dieser situation die lage und sollte es
nicht wieder angemacht werden die
abschlüsse angekommen dann
kann man sich ausrechnen die grafik hoch
gehalten dass wir jetzt bei 40 stream
belastung noch ein speichern können wir
jedoch wegfallen werden würde ist
entsprechend weitere maßnahmen
erforderlich machen ein kurzer hinweis
wir werden im laufe des tages die grafik
und die dahinterliegenden berechnungen
auf veröffentlichen insofern können sie
da gerne auch noch nachschauen vorher zu
bitte haben sie schon super dann waren
die kollegen super schnell
fallen wird
alle länder die in der gasförderung sind
versuchen die kapazitäten zu erhöhen das
tun sie aus der solidarität heraus aber
natürlich auch weil die preise e mails
sind also es ist durchaus lukrativ im
moment gas auf den markt zu bringen die
betonung liegt sicherlich auch auf dem
moment das ist sicherlich ein
ausnahmezustand der so auf dauer nicht
bleiben wird das problem ist halt das
gasfelder zu entwickeln beziehungsweise
die kapazitäten zu steigern nicht so
ganz trivial ist man kann hier und da
noch bcm vielleicht zwei oder drei mehr
produzieren aber nicht auf schnitt große
gasfelder erschließen das dauert dann
zwei drei jahre oder 34 jahre
trotzdem bemühen sich alle länder das zu
tun und das funktioniert auch wir haben
gesehen dass aus den anderen ländern
größere gasmengen auf den markt gebracht
werden usa kanada norwegen
israel ägypten algerien alle tun ihren
beitrag und das sind die lieferanten
quellen die die dann genutzt werden vom
markt also was wir machen können was ich
machen kann was die bundesregierung
macht es diese länder zu ermutigen sie
anzusprechen die situation zu erklären
und die verträge werden aber ja nicht
von uns gemacht sondern dann von den
energieversorgungsunternehmen die sich
dann das günstigste gas auf dem markt
besorgen um dann ihren verpflichtungen
nachzukommen
dann würde ich jetzt einmal in den
digitalen raum wechseln jana wolf bitte
danach herr lochner und dann herr
wiedemann frau wolff sie machen den
anfang
vielen dank hallo herr habe hannover
kabel ich würde gerne nochmal bei den
entlastungen
nach varanasi sprachen von extremen
belastungen für viele menschen
unternehmen und unternehmern und das ist
die aufgabe der nächsten wochen sein
wird für eine faire aufteilung zu sorgen
was ist denn da an konkreten schritten
schon angedacht
inwiefern hat das seine kondition
ausschuss eine rolle gespielt und was
bedeutet dass perspektivisch für das
ziel eines ausgeglichenen haushalts und
die einhaltung der schuldenbremse
vielen dank
der bundeskanzler hat die konzertierte
aktion einberufen
das ist eine antwort auf die
makroökonomische herausforderung die wir
haben hohe inflation die
mit allen mitteln die wir zur verfügung
haben nicht zu einer rezession werden
darf also das verhindert wird dass es
eine lohn-preis-spirale gibt hohe
inflation führt nach jeder denkbaren
formen dazu dass man höhere
lohnforderungen hat der verlust muss ja
ausgeglichen werden chor und
jugendförderung führen zu noch höheren
preisen führen zu einer noch höheren
inflation und so weiter und so fort das
ist mit den arbeitgebervertretern mit
den gewerkschaften vor gesprochen worden
dass diese situation die dann aus der
hohen inflation eine rezession machen
kann so verhindert werden muss und wie
man sie verhindern kann das ist teil der
gespräche die der bundeskanzler führen
wird und die dann ja anfang juli
stattfinden werden dem möchte ich nicht
vorgreifen schon gar nicht würde ich sie
zerstören indem ich das spiel mitmachen
das so gerne gespielt wird jeder haut
seine vorschläge auf dem markt und dann
werden die zerredet und am ende ist es
eine machtprobe zwischen parteien welche
der vorschlag dann am besten aus kommt
ich glaube hier muss man tatsächlich mal
ein bisschen von ihm ihr zurückhaltung
üben und damit der sinnvollste vorschlag
oder die besten ideen dann auch
überhaupt nur eine chance zu haben
umgesetzt zu werden
das interessante damit will ich
schließen ist das und das ist eine nicht
schließen diese frage noch beantworten
das ist eine finde ich sehr
hoffnungsvolle erkenntnis ist dass die
klarheit der außergewöhnlichen situation
in der wir uns befinden bei arbeitgebern
den industrievertretern im mittelstand
standlern wie bei den gewerkschaften und
den arbeitnehmervertreterin voll da ist
und das die analyse auch eine sehr
gleiche ist denn
selbst oder gerade die arbeitgeber haben
ja kein interesse an einer schwächung
der kaufkraft bei gestört und
lieferketten und blockierten
exportmärkten ist natürlich zentral
wichtig dass die deutsche
binnennachfrage erhalten bleibt also
gibt es ein interesse der arbeitgeber an
einer erhalten der kaufkraft umgekehrt
haben natürlich die arbeitnehmer die
gewerkschaftsvertreterin kein interesse
dass deutschland ein und attraktiver
standort wird und branche industrien
geschlossen werden oder abwandern also
gibt es quasi eine spiegel gleiche
erkenntnis der situation und wie die
aufgelöst werden soll wie man auch
politisch helfen kann sie aufzulösen das
wird hoffentlich dann in einem
vertrauten rahmen gegenstand der
gespräche der konzertierten aktion seien
dann bitte herr lochner
haben nicht da sie haben das
optionsmodell wind um damit die
industrie sozusagen zum gas sparen an
gereizt wird da ist jetzt ja der
zeitraum im sommer angegeben vielleicht
können sie das noch ein bisschen mehr
einen grenzen den zeitraum und was hören
sie denn aus der industrie zu
bereitschaft an diesem modell dann auch
tatsächlich teilzunehmen danke
die industrie
ist sehr bereit dieses modell anzunehmen
und setzt da ein stück weit drauf und
unterstützt uns auch bei der
zusammenstellung der daten
also das ist ein instrument das
hoffentlich eine gewisse wirkung und
wenn man eine große hoffnung hat mehr
als eine gewisse wirkung erzielen kann
gas verbräuche zu reduzieren ist
natürlich jetzt schon durch den
preisdruck eigentlich das gebot der
stunde in das tun auch viele ich habe
die zahlen genannt
geiste gasverbraucher zu reduzieren ist
aber natürlich auch mit kosten
möglicherweise verursacht wenn die dann
erworben werden können oder ausgeglichen
werden können die man geld dafür bekommt
wird es noch mal attraktiver dort
einzusteigen also die industrie ist der
ihm sehr sehr aufgeschlossen gegenüber
dass wir das modell erst im sommer an
den start bringen können liegt wie so
bei so viel daran dass es keine
vorbereitungen dafür gab als ich ankam
ich habe das schon mehrfach erzählt
hatte man im grunde gar keine
politischen instrumente aber auch keine
erkenntnisse über das funktionieren des
gasmarktes man muss einfach einräumen
dass viele gesetze die eine trügerische
sicherheit
ausgestrahlt haben überhaupt nicht für
diese situation gedacht und geschrieben
waren
vielleicht also ich nehme diese gas
notfallverordnung auf europäischer ebene
die er sagt wir schalten die industrien
hat die letzte verbraucher sind
geschützt
das szenario dass dieser verordnung zu
grunde liegt ist nicht eine
auseinandersetzung eine permanente
auseinandersetzung um eine fossile
energie versorgung sondern vielleicht
eine störung durch unfall also irgend
eine gasleitung geht kaputt und für ein
paar tage ist die versorgungssicherheit
in einer bestimmten regierung nicht
gewährleistet und das macht es natürlich
total sinn zu sagen ja dann fahren wir
halt die industrie prozesse für eine
woche runter das kann der staat
ausgleichen und dann ist die leitung
wieder heile gemacht dann geht es wieder
weiter aber vielen soll da keiner für
diese situation die wir jetzt aber haben
ist diese verordnung sagen wir zu
pauschal so war die bundesnetzagentur
die abwehr gesetzt das ist ja ein altes
gesetz als bundes last verteiler für die
notfall stufe 1 treten soll und dann
regulieren soll welche falls die märkte
wirklich versagen welche industrien
welche branchen welche region nicht mehr
mit gas versorgt werden natürlich darauf
angewiesen dass die kenntnisse über die
verbräuche in den regionen hat und über
energiesparen und wenn man richtig dran
denkt auch kenntnisse über die
lieferketten hätte gar keinen sinn
irgendeinen unternehmens rauszunehmen
weil man denkt man ja das ist vielleicht
eher entbehrlich und dann danach
festzustellen dass ganze ketten der der
der versorgung von deutschland dadurch
zusammenbrechen diese daten gab es gar
nicht noch nicht mal auf papier und was
die bundesnetzagentur unter hochdruck
macht mit dem
trading harburg ist diese daten zu
sammeln die daten der unternehmen
einzulegen in eine software die mit
einem algorithmus geführt und dann
ermöglicht je nach szenario die
richtigen entscheidungen zu treffen
diese plattform nutzen wir dann auch um
das markt instrument einzusetzen und
deswegen dauert es halt ein bisschen
länger es ist nicht die schlüssigkeit
der kolleginnen und kollegen die dazu
führt dass wir das erst im sommer
einsetzen können sondern die
schlüssigkeit der jahre zuvor und es ist
der fleiß der kollegin und der kollegen
dienen einer windeseile diese daten
gesammelt haben eine software ein
programm gebaut haben programmiert haben
das es uns ermöglicht dann kluge
entscheidungen zu treffen vor allem erst
einmal marktbasierte kluge
entscheidungen zu treffen
man sieht allerdings auch dass
deutschland in der digitalisierung von
prozessen nicht nur beim ausbau von
erneuerbaren energien noch ganz schön
was aufzuholen hat herr wiedemann bitte
ja morgen eine frage dabei jetzt zum
zeitpunkt die jetzt auszurufen warum
haben sie das nicht schon vergangene
woche gemacht denn die gas stöße gegen
jahr seit vergangener woche im dienstag
oder mittwoch stark zurück also was
braucht ihr jetzt noch diese
vorbereitung dass sie das heute machen
ich schon ein paar tage eher
die durchdringung der marktanalyse ich
habe nichts zu sagen ja gerade erwähnt
wir haben das einmal durchgerechnet und
ich will das noch mal sagen das ist hier
kein spiel das wir spielen das ausrufen
der alarmstufe ist eine
ein schritt der
außergewöhnlich ist
und ich habe darauf hingewiesen dass wir
in der gegenwart also für den tag für
die tage die wir gerade haben genug gas
bekommen und die speicher ja auch zu
nehmen also die speicherstände haben
sich in den letzten vor der reduktion
des gases hatten wir zu namen von 0,8
prozent 0 9 prozent teilweise also fast
knappes prozent jetzt hat er sich
halbiert in den letzten tagen schwanken
zwischen 0,3 und 0,5 den letzten 24
stunden 0,3 der speicherstadt betrieb
jetzt 58,7 prozent also wir nähern uns
langsam der 60 an also wenn man auf den
takt denkt man nach na ja die lage ist
auf trotz der reduktion bewältigt war
der markt funktioniert gas kommt nach
europa die speicher werden auch langsam
voller langsamer als zuvor wie sie
langsam voller und das was uns
alarmieren muss ist die perspektive und
die perspektive haben wir einmal sauber
durchgerechnet und so würde ich es gerne
halten uns nicht durch die irakischen
entscheidungen oder die strategischen
rate schon entscheidung von putin
treiben zu lassen sondern
möglichst alle szenarien politisch
vorbereitet zu haben und dann auf der
basis von tatsächlichen fakten lagen die
entscheidungen treffen
dann bitte her in und danach gehe ich
wieder in den physischen raum
guten morgen ist das denn
ich hätte eine frage ob es kalkulation
in ihrem haus gibt wie stark denn die
preise noch zulegen werden in den
nächsten monaten das ist ein blick in
die glaskugel
aber sie brauchen ja irgend eine
grundannahme um überhaupt auch ist
angebote für bleibt die verbraucher und
auch die wirtschaft kalkulieren zu
können
es gibt szenarien aber wie es so wie sie
sagen die sind natürlich nicht sehr
verlässlich wir liegen jetzt für die
kalkulation die wir haben den aktuellen
gaspreis zu wohnende plus - also in dem
range indem wir sind ich war ein
bisschen heute 125
euro dass es waren schon mal 130 nach
der verkündigung von putin ist es ein
bisschen runtergegangen auch von der cdu
schwankte zwischen 110 115 und 130 heute
ist 125 der gaspreis war aber auch schon
mal bei 300 euro und ist dann also bei
kriegsbeginn ist dann wieder runter
gegangen also das sind wirklich große
sprünge am markt schwer zu kalkulieren
aber wir nehmen schon einen höheren wert
an
haben auch szenarien natürlich dass die
werte exorbitant hoch gehen natürlich
könnten sie auch theoretisch wieder
runter gehen nicht so sehr
wahrscheinlich dann bitte wieder in den
physischen raum frau pinzler zunächst
dann herr traufetter und dann
habe ich wie sehr können sie für
deutschland tatsächlich planen da wir ja
zur solidarität mit anderen europäischen
ländern verpflichtet sind wie sehr ihn
das die kalkulation kaputt und noch eine
ganz kurze zweite frage wie sehr fühlen
sie sich eigentlich allein in der
bundesregierung wo sie immer zum sparen
aufrufen aber die anderen eher steigen
ich fühle mich überhaupt nicht lange in
der bundesregierung sondern bin den
kollegen dankbar dass sie den weg
unterstützen dass sie das geld
bereitstellen die gestern 15 milliarden
das ja auch kein pappenstiel
wurden bewilligt und zwar sowohl von
finanzministerien wie im
haushaltsausschuss die hilfsprogramme
für die unternehmen die wir aufgestellt
haben alles ist einem guten
zusammenspiel erfolgt und gerade die
vorbereitenden maßnahmen die wir seit
dezember getroffen haben die kenntnisse
die wir erworben haben sind auch im
engen zusammenspiel mit dem kanzleramt
erworben also da es ist eine sehr gute
kooperation und von einsamkeit kann
keine rede sein die
erste frage war
die einer europäischen länder ich habe
schon gesagt im grunde verbietet sich
die frage jetzt hier über nationale
alleingänge nachzudenken gerade für
deutschland denn gefördert ja nur noch
einen kleinen teil unser gas verbräuche
selbst im eigenen land sind also darauf
angewiesen dass andere länder durch
leighton beziehungsweise und ihre lng
terminals zur verfügung stellen ohne die
könnten wir gleich einpacken also sind
wir umgekehrt natürlich auch
verpflichtet das was wir an
möglichkeiten haben den europäischen
nachbarn zur verfügung zu stellen die
europäischen nachbarn wiederum sollten
alles an ihrer stelle alles für sie
mögliche tun ebenfalls die gasse
herunter zu bringen beziehungsweise
ihrer speicher hoch zu halten und das
ist auch ein signal des heutigen tages
nach europa das jedenfalls die deutsche
bundesregierung und dieses ministerium
und ich in persona der meinung bin wir
müssen noch besser werden
dann bitte als nächstes hätte auf hätte
für die
energieversorgungssicherheit es
entscheidend dass diese zwei ersten
terminals gebaut werden und da hört man
dass die planung jetzt nicht so voran
schreitet das
dass sie da zufrieden sein können stimmt
das und was machen sie oder hat
möglicherweise jetzt auch diese
ausrufung der alarmstufe noch mal ein
bisschen mehr die nachdrücklichkeit
unterstrichen
wir begleiten die planung und den bau
eng und es geht auch gut voran richtig
ist dass immer wieder konkrete einzelne
probleme auftreten sobald wir davon zu
hören bekommen lösen wir sie
dann mit ihrer
arbeit noch mal zur
preisanpassungsklausel wie weit sind wir
aus ihrer sicht von einer strukturellen
gasmenge lage noch entfernt und gibt es
andere szenarien aus dass nord stream 1
auf 0 prozent versorgung runtergeht dass
es zu dieser strukturellen mangel arge
kommt die strukturellen mangel lage ist
daran gebunden dass wir die versorgung
nicht mehr
sicherstellen können in deutschland da
sind wir also noch länger von entfernt
in der realität
dass vorsorge paradox greift hier ein
stück weit um diese realität nicht
eintreten zu lassen also im winter ein
szenario wir sagen jetzt müssen wir
abschalten bzw wir haben tatsächlich zu
wenig gas und die versorgungssicherheit
in deutschland zu gewährleisten müssen
wir jetzt vorsorge treffen obwohl noch
genug da gas da ist obwohl ja niemand
der bei seinem verstand ist jetzt seine
wohnung oder sein haus heißt deswegen
diese im gewissen sinne
widersprüchliche situation im moment ist
alles gut aber der moment darf nicht
darüber hinwegtäuschen dass wenn wir im
moment verharren alles schlecht wird und
deswegen werden wir über die
verschiedenen gesetze das ausrufen der
alarmstufe
unseren teil dazu beitragen dass dieses
vorsorge paradoxon aufgelöst wird dass
wir uns nicht in einer trügerischen
sicherheit wägen und danach feststellen
das hätten wir mal lieber nicht tun
sollen aber natürlich das ist mir völlig
klar wir arbeiten am ende gegen die
menschliche allzumenschliche
erwartungshaltung an das schließt mich
ein und ich glaube jeder weiß dass von
sich selbst dass man so reden wie ich
das hier halte von politikern irgendwie
da rein daraus wird und sagt na ja aber
jetzt gehe ich raus und für geehrt
werden und dann hat man wieder vergessen
was eigentlich gerade phase ist und
diese diese vergesslichkeit diese selbst
eigentlich hätten wir alle in uns haben
die ist unser größter feind und die
müssen wir jetzt versuchen aufzubrechen
ich glaube durch eine gemeinsame
kraftanstrengung also nicht durch den
appell jeder muss sondern wir alle
können
dann bitte wieder in den digitalen raum
herr skupin herr bollmann und dann hsg
vielen dank herr habe ich noch eine
frage zum energie sicherungs gesetz die
sagten ja vorhin so kommentiert noch
nicht können die preise erhöht sofort
werden heißt das sie rechnen für die
nächsten tage wochen damit und was es
eigentlich die voraussetzungen jetzt
noch mal konkret dass das passiert noch
einmal in die preise werden erhöht und
zwar regulär und ich würde sagen und
abwendbar denn die höheren energiekosten
sind ja nicht erst in der zukunft dar
sondern haben wir schon stark und die
energieversorgungsunternehmen geben sie
an die kunden weiter auch die industrie
gibt wo sie kann die preise an die
kunden weiter das führt zu der hohen
inflation
das worüber wir reden ist eine
sprunghafte oder plötzliche sofortige
weitergabe innerhalb der bestehenden
verträge sie verträgt man kann quasi als
versorgungsunternehmen aus den verträgen
heraus treten und sagen ich habe so hohe
kosten die kann ich nicht mehr tragen
dann fällig um dann über lieblich das
nicht mehr als unternehmen und dann gebe
ich es an die verbraucher weiter und
diese situation kann passieren das habe
ich schon ausgeführt die viele
energieversorgungsunternehmen machen im
moment - weil sie ihre verträge bedienen
müssen aber die verträge sind günstiger
als die einkaufsmengen das nicht daran
dass zumindestens wenn sie sich auf
russisches gas verlassen haben dies ja
nun reduziert ist also müssen sie die
mengen am spot markt einkaufen damit
machen sie mit der erfüllung ihrer
verträge ein - und ich habe auch schon
jeweils angedeutet was das politische
risiko ist wenn ein gasversorgung oder
ein energieversorgungsunternehmen nicht
mehr am markt bestehen kann dann geht es
nicht mehr um dieses unternehmen alleine
sondern um den markt selbst und wie weit
wieder von dem fernsehen dass
spekulation aber es ist jedenfalls bei
den hohen preisen und bei der
politischen lage in der wir uns befinden
ein szenario das wir sehr ernst nehmen
dann bitte herr bäumen ja aber guten
morgen ich habe zwei kurze fragen dass
eine bezieht sich auch die
internationale dimension die sich auch
schon ein paar mal gestrafft haben mit
blick auf mögliche lieferländer wie usa
oder auch andere länder die ist nicht in
der ähnliche notlage vielleicht in
deutschland befinden italien zum
beispiel erwarten sie da irgendwelche
beschlüsse jetzt von den anstehenden
gipfeltreffen eu g7 was sozusagen
westliche energie solidarität betrifft
wenn ich das mal so pathetisch
ausdrücken darf und die zweite frage ist
wir haben jetzt auch schon ein paar mal
über preise gesprochen
inwieweit erhalten sie ist es für
möglich dass der bund der staat die
gaspreise sozusagen schon an der quelle
subventioniert im grunde diese 15
milliarden zu speichern sind ja wenn man
es recht betrachtet eigentlich schon der
der einstieg in so eine gas sanierung
dankeschön die 15 milliarden die wir
jetzt am markt besorgen liegen darin
begründet dass einige unternehmen nicht
mehr die liquidität haben die gasmengen
am markt zu besorgen das geht natürlich
vor allem für die töchter von gazprom
germania die jetzt nicht mehr gazprom
germania heißt sondern energy security
früher wenn ich das richtig weiß
die ja die müssten ja quasi rubel von
putin bekommen und die deutschen
energiemarkt zu versorgen das ist ja
sanktioniert und findet nicht mehr statt
dann hängen aber hinter der tochter
wingas beispielsweise viele stadtwerke
wenn die kein geld mehr bekommen vom
eigentümer gazprom noch immer dann muss
halt jemand anderes einspringen dieses
geld ist allerdings keine subvention ist
auch nicht weg sondern wird ja ein gas
angelegt und mit einer ich würde sagen
sehr sehr hohen wahrscheinlichkeit wird
es dann auch irgendwann gebraucht werden
zu den preisen die dann eben am markt
erzielt werden das ist also ein beitrag
zur liquidität kein geschenk es wird
wieder reinkommen und die darlehen
laufzeit ist gebunden an ende 25
also dieses geld ist keine subvention
sondern eine
notwendige maßnahme
des staates dafür zu sorgen dass genug
geld da ist die speicher zu füllen nun
voll zu kriegen und trading cup europe
die das geld verwalten sind dann auch
nicht in der konkurrenz zu den
unternehmen sondern sie nehmen die
scheiben in den speichern die nicht
durch markt gefüllt werden also reden
vor allem gazprom eigentümer
bezieht aber auch andere speicher können
sie eintreten wenn sie sehen dass dort
die gesetzliche speicherverpflichtung
nicht ausgeübt werden oder werden können
also das ist er sozusagen die füllung
der marktlücke aber keine subvention
ansonsten
denke ich dass wir insgesamt
lernen und für das vielleicht auch schon
vorher hinweise gab dass ein eingriff in
den preis
nie die beste alternative ist weil die
preis wirkung natürlich auch dazu
beiträgt dass effizienzen gehoben werden
das soll nicht zynisch klingen weil ich
weiss nicht unterstreicht das noch
einmal wie sehr menschen und unternehmen
darunter leiden dass die preise so hoch
sind aber würde man die preise
abschneiden oder würde man die hälfte
der preis oder irgendeine summe
subventionieren und sagen dann musst du
nicht mehr so teuer
würde man ja das fatale signal setzen
macht einfach weiter wie bisher
um die preiseffekte abzufedern ist eine
gezielte unterstützung der unternehmen
und der bürgerinnen und bürger der
verbraucher an verbraucher die es
brauchen das politisch bessere
instrument
ich würde jetzt noch drei fragen dran
nehmen und zwar die kolleginnen und
kollegen die sich die noch nicht dran
kamen die weiteren fragen würde ich dann
gerne auf den hintergrund verweisen und
staatssekretär reichen und klaus müller
chef der bundesnetzagentur
die stehen auch gleich noch zu für
fragen zur verfügung
deswegen jetzt bitte herbst gehen dann
frau hülsen und dann malte kreutzfeldt
bitte und danach würden wir uns dann im
hintergrund wieder sehen
können sie sagen vielleicht sie haben
von den berechnungen gesprochen in ihrem
ministerium könne nicht sagen wann kommt
dazu eine rationierung des
gases für die industrie können sie das
vielleicht
voraussehen irgendwelche monat ist es
soweit kommen wird
ich kann nur sagen hoffentlich nie das
ist ein politisches szenario wo es keine
richtigen entscheidungen ergibt sondern
vielleicht nur weniger falsche all die
maßnahmen sind darauf ausgerichtet dass
wir die marktkräfte so weit wie es geht
wirksam halten und andere alternativen
schaffen einsparungen andere
energieträger ausbau von infrastruktur
um dieses szenario abzufinden
frage was soll ich nicht es soll nicht
passieren keinem monat im besten fall
ich kann es natürlich nicht ausschließen
weil es so voraussetzung reiches was wir
tun aber es ist kein szenario auf das
wir hinarbeiten im gegenteil
phrasen bitte und dann malte kreutzfeldt
morgen eine frage noch mal zum artikel
24 wird es jetzt die aufgabe der
kommenden wochen seien entlastungen zu
finden für den moment in dem der artikel
24 dann auch gezogen wird oder ist es
auch eine erwägung den artikel 24 selbst
nochmal anzufassen und die mechanismen
zu ändern die darin bisher vorgesehen
sind für die preisgabe
der artikel 24 oder § 24 ist ich habe
schon gesagt ein sehr scharfes schwert
er ist an die voraussetzungen gebunden
dass die bundesnetzagentur
nach einer längeren betrachtung der
machtverhältnisse die gas notlage dann
aus ruft in deutschland und für alles
würde ich sagen dass wir in einem
prozess uns befinden
wo wir immer neu lernen das heißt ich
will für kein gesetz dass wir gemacht
haben
sagen das ist jetzt das letzte mal dass
wir ein gesetz angefasst haben wir sind
ja auch gedanklich in einem bereich wo
noch niemand vorher war und
deswegen ist die erwartungshaltung die
manchmal auch im politischen raum
geäußert wird da gibt es die eine große
lösung gegen einen großen gipfel falsch
der gipfel ist eine permanente arbeit
die krisenbewältigung ist ein
permanentes arbeiten mit den
verschiedenen unternehmen den
vertretungen den verbraucher vertreterin
kapazitäten kollegen aus den ländern in
der koalition
und so sind auch jetzt diese tage also
ich rede mit in den konferenzen mit den
energieministern den ländern mit der
wirtschaft mit den energieversorgern mit
dem verbraucher vertreterin bald so
ergeben sich natürlich jede menge neue
erkenntnisse und ich will das für mich
sagen ich brauche diese kollektive
kreativität oder wir brauchen diese
konnektivität um immer besser zu werden
und wenn wir das ministerium auch meine
person immer fokussiert sind auf die
dinge über die wir jetzt in ihrer
pressekonferenz geredet habe sehen wir
vielleicht an anderer stelle gesetzes
normen möglichkeiten noch andere
elemente zu heben die in anderen
fachbereichen liegen also brauche ich
den zuruf von bürgerinnen und bürgern
von den kollegen aus den ländern oder
auch von den kollegen im kabinett die
sagen da kann es auch noch was machen
und es gibt solche sachen alle ihr tag
gestern hat mich auch drei oder vier
neue gesetzesinitiativen gebracht weil
ich nicht weiß ob sie tragen aber die
jetzt am haus abgearbeitet werden
insofern glaube ich müssen wir einfach
nur so ehrlich sein dass wir hier in
einer gemeinsamen lernen bewegung uns
befinden und die macht uns besser
meinte kreutzfeldt zum abschluss bitte
vielen dank
während einerseits ist die gas notlage
ausrufen ist ja werden andererseits
gegen tag in deutschland auf neue
gasheizung in wohnungen und häuser
eingebaut sie hatten ja da habe ich bei
dem koalitionsgipfel im märz schon
versucht dieses verbot von neuen
gasheizungen vorzuziehen sind damit aber
gescheitert gibt es denn da jetzt
überlegungen dass man in einer solchen
situation wie jetzt auch das vielleicht
nochmal anfasst und keine neuen
gasverbraucher ans netz nimmt der
alarmstufe die wir heute ausrufen die
notfall stufe wäre dann der nächste
schritt nur dass das nicht die
katholisch durcheinander geht es ist
tatsächlich so dass ab 2024 so dass der
letzte der vorletzte koalitionsausschuss
verabredet die der anteil der
erneuerbaren energien im wärmebereich
bei 65 prozent liegen muss das sind ganz
häufig ist wird ein paar mal
techniken geben aber ganz häufig dann
wärmepumpen die dann hinauf anteil der
erneuerbaren energien elektrisch geführt
ein anteil der erneuerbaren zum betrieb
haben die frage ob man das noch weiter
vorziehen kann es plötzlich eine frage
ob der markt das bewältigen kann wir
haben demnächst einen wärmepumpen gipfel
zusammen mit der kollegin klara geywitz
der versucht die umstellung im markt
erst einmal stärker anzuregen mein
eindruck ist dass das was wir im moment
erleben eine totale trendumkehr ist sehr
viele
installationsbetriebe sind ja auf
gasheizung spezialisiert gewesen ich
will nicht sagen die königs anders aber
sie müssen sich erstmal darauf
einstellen dass das was gestern noch
gewollt und ja bis zum antritt dieser
regierung auch politisch gefördert wurde
dass das jetzt nicht mehr richtig ist
und deswegen ist die umstellung die
umstellung findet jetzt schon stadt
gesetzlich 324 normiert ich weiß gar
nicht ob das weitere vorziehen zu einem
sofortigen effekt kommen würde
jedenfalls dieses politisch noch nicht
vereinbart
einsatz finde ich noch sagen das habe
ich für ihn übersprungen die frage nach
europäischer kooperation wenn ich das
noch sagen darf das ist natürlich im g 7
gipfel und beim rat wo alles geredet
wird etwas anderes als bei den
fachministerkonferenz die wir dann ab
montag und dienstag in luxemburg haben
aber ich habe schon darauf hingewiesen
dass wir besser in einem gemeinsamen
markt sind und deswegen wäre natürlich
erstens ist notwendig dass man die
gemeinsamen leitungen die infrastruktur
zusammen entwickelt und barrieren auf
hebt das gilt für den gas später
wasserstoff bereich aber auch natürlich
für den strombereich zweitens und das
ist geht will ich noch mal
unterstreichen ist der beschleunigte
ausbau von energieeffizienzmaßnahmen und
erneuerbaren energien ein großer teil
der lösung und der findet übrigens statt
man guckt jetzt auf die oberfläche man
sieht durch meine presseankündigung aber
es muss auch noch kohlekraftwerke wieder
anmachen und lng terminals bauen und das
ist die oberfläche und sie ist eine
zerbeulte zerkratzte ganz schwierige
oberfläche und auch keine die mich
glücklich geschweige denn stolz macht
unterhalb der oberfläche registrieren
wir eine wahnsinnige dynamik bei der
sanierung von häusern bei den
investitionen der unternehmen die alle
schneller ihre thema neutralität
projekte vorziehen wollen als es jemals
gedacht war das heißt dass die
europäische kooperation die eigentliche
dynamik unter der oberfläche die so
schwierig ist moment unterstützen muss
nicht ab wirkung auf sondern mit
gesetzen mit förderstrukturen mit den
notwendigen maßnahmen den projekten
beispielsweise aber auch schnellen
genehmigen unterstützen muss und auch
das können wir natürlich in diesem
halben jahr noch schaffen da wo wir noch
wärme durch nutzung von abwärme nutzung
von abwasserwärme nutzung von biogas
anlagen nutzung von solarthermie
reduzieren können das sollten wir es tun
und noch mal
die summe von vielen kleinen maßnahmen
hilft dann am ende fiel
vielen dank vielen dank dass sie so
kurzfristig zu dieser pressekonferenz
gekommen sind
gutes gelingen beim schreiben beim
umsetzen und ich wünsche ihnen einen
schönen tag noch bis zu lang